you know who's doing it right those wine
bars with machines where you put in the
card by tastings of various types of
wine they're kind of like Dave &
Buster's except they're not for the
lowest class of human beings on the
planet these spots are great because
they allow you to sample overpriced
wines without having to shell out $100
for the entire bottle plus you can just
lie to your friends and say you're
drinking the price see which one am i
drinking my dear boy
the most expensive obviously only the
best for this guy I can really taste the
fruits in this vintage quite quite
fruity yes that's coconut it's coconut
of fruit or nut it's quite quite nutty
these places really do make it feel like
your wine tasting in Napa Valley - the
over-explaining [ __ ] who treats you
like an infant because it's painfully
obvious you know nothing about wine
salut you know who's doing it right
you're one single friend who never seems
to date yet still manages to get laid
all the time